él estaba diciendo cosas malas y
mentiras sobre mí en las redes sociales
así que imprimir las capturas de
pantalla lleve sus sudaderas a su casa y
pegue las capturas de pantalla en el
paquete para que su mamá
vaya
reunimos a siete personas que han sido
engañadas soy tibian y he sido engañado
me llamo ángel y me han engañado hola me
llamo morgan y me han engañado
yo soy mediana y me han engañado hola
soy vivían y me engañaron hola me llamo
abi me han engañado hola me llamo earl y
ni me han engañado
uno de ellos es infiel si el grupo
descubre quién es el infiel repartirá el
premio en efectivo
si el infiel sobrevive se ganará todo el
premio
quién es el infiel
y
saben quién es el infiel
en clases de psicología dijeron que
cuando hablas con alguien debes mirarlo
a los ojos y hacerle una pregunta
podríamos empezar a hacerlo alguien
quiere preguntar aunque el genial diría
se dilatan un poco y todo eso es de él
asumió un papel de líder tal vez hizo
esa pregunta para poder dar su respuesta
preparada y tratar de convencer yo le
haría una pregunta bien directa haciendo
trampa crees que después de eso podrías
redimirse por realidad y me lo creo
tiene muchos matices en la mayoría de
los casos no pero en mi caso me
engañaron dos veces una de las veces
tenía 15 años pensé acaso esa persona
sería infiel toda su vida y no lo creo
si éramos los niños si no decir que hay
algunos atenuantes digamos en mi caso no
soy una persona celosa si estás borracha
en un bar y besas a un extraño y te
sientes mal por eso puedo entenderlo
pero si decides ir a casa de alguien eso
no impide que haya una conexión eso fue
lo que me pasó a mí dijo que si tú ves a
alguien en un bar o algo así no es tan
malo yo pienso que esa es una forma de
hacer trampa no me parece que sea
correcto así que creo que ella es la
infiel para mí depende de la persona y
de cuánto esté dispuesta hacer para que
funcione y cambie soy un señor que puede
exiliar pero si solo pone excusas como
lo siento cariño no volverá a ocurrir
perseo de desminar durante un periodo de
tiempo y luego volverá a suceder
entonces donde queda la promesa de
cambiar o trata de minimizar lo que
ocurrió también depende de a quién le
importa porque sé que a algunos les
importa engañar y a otros no a algunos
les parece incluso algo aceptable aunque
a la mayoría no le gusta engañar al otro
no no
[Música]
sé que tiene mucha confianza pero se
siente como si siguiera un libreto
subsidian dijo que no a todos nos
importa engañar a otro y para mí estuvo
fuera del lugar
tenemos un empate
el empate es entre hábil y tibia
si bien quieres empezar tú primero en
realidad no tuve mucho tiempo de hablar
así que preferí dejar que ustedes lo
dijeran todo me engañaron cuando estaba
estudiando en la universidad y me
pareció muy interesante lo que dijiste
si tú bien por qué dijiste que podrías
perdonar a alguien que besara a una
persona completamente extraña y eso me
recuerda a lo que me dijo mi ex es muy
interesante
en realidad crecí en un hogar indio
tradicional la forma en que me criaron
fue que siempre debía tratar a la mujer
con respeto pienso que mi historia es
muy interesante como descubrí que mi
novia me engañaba vi su foto en facebook
con otro sujeto ella me dijo fuimos
grandes amigos por dos años y habíamos
estado saliendo durante los dos años en
serio esa es mi historia
[Música]
sabía que sería el primero en ser
eliminado no me extraña siempre me ven
como un jugador para mí es algo que
tiene mucho sentido al engañarte
cometiste alguna locura yo estuve y
estuve a punto cuando me engañaron me lo
guardé durante una semana porque sé que
fue difícil no sé por qué me tortura
pero era porque estaba tan enojada que
quise planear como vengarme sí sí y
terminé confiando en uno de sus
argumentos no ocurrió lo mismo en
realidad no recurrí a la venganza sino
que fui golpe al sujeto porque lo
encontré en las redes sociales y
descubrí que el tiempo se trata de
encontrar a la stasi que le sugerí que
se encontrarán en el cheesecake factory
y pensé voy a presentarme allí qué
locura para mí entonces me presente en
el lugar ellos estaban en su cita todo
fue planeado detenidamente entré y ella
simplemente se puso a gritar llorando y
diciendo lo siento discúlpame de verdad
lo siento mucho si esto sucedió así lo
siento mucho pero a mí me pareció una
locura fue como una obra maestra
cinematográfica algo ojalá yo pudiera
hacer eso no se lo deseo saben a qué me
refiere en mi caso yo trataba de tener
una relación a larga distancia de una
semana después de que se fue me engañó
por lilly estaba diciendo cosas malas y
mentiras sobre mí en las redes sociales
así que imprimir las capturas de
pantalla lleve sus sudaderas a su casa
las dejé en casa de sus padres y pedí a
las capturas de pantalla en el paquete
para que su madre las pudiera leer
no creo que yo estaba llena de ira saben
a qué me refiero llena de fe expansión
ser como si no pudiera haber con
claridad en ese momento quería que
sintiera lo que yo sentía no entiendo y
fácil de controlar que solo quisiera
saber cuál es la definición de engaño
para un hombre es algo que según mente
qué significa amar a tienda no lo sé esa
definición depende de cada individuo
puede variar mucho y algunos seguramente
estén de acuerdo conmigo depende de lo
que piense cada uno pero con respecto a
lo típico cómo conectarse con otra
persona coquetear con otra persona
continuar como una relación teniendo
otra persona para mí eso es engañar al
otro si es un engaño físico y emocional
es lo que también iba puedo aclarar lo
que dije en la última ronda porque
detestaría descartar a alguien que haya
tenido la experiencia de besar a un
extraño no lo sé lo siento si eso fue lo
que pasó eso es porque yo no soy una
persona celosa hay algunos actos que
aunque sean un engaño yo sé que si
estuviera con la persona correcta en la
relación correcta yo sería capaz de
perdonarlo también es la intención
si alguien lo hace con mala intención
como si quisiera hacerte daño si quiere
terminar la relación pero si todavía
tiene una relación sí así que es algo
que debes pensarlo muy bien y decidir si
fue algo malo yo siento que aunque no
quisieron dejar a toda mi generación sé
que en esta época tenemos relaciones y
no mantenemos los límites lo bastante
firme sobre lo que piensan que es su
definición de engaño siento que es sobre
todo cuando te engañan a una edad
temprana dejamos que las emociones nos
controlen un poco más si siento que es
natural que la gente pueda cometer
locuras a esa edad
erin hering abi
viviane a pl contó esa historia ideal de
cómo se vengó de su ex también podría
ser algo que se suele ver en el cine
morgan
de nuevo tenemos un empate desempate es
entre abi y erding si realmente me
sorprende mucho que haya otro empate yo
he sido demasiado informal no me
sorprendió que me eligieran vivía en la
misma ciudad que mi ex y debía mudarme
sabíamos que había una fecha límite hubo
un periodo de tres semanas donde nos
llamamos por teléfono pusimos una fecha
para nuestra ruptura dos días antes de
la fecha fue un evento del orgullo gay y
se unió a otra persona si la vas a
engañar deja primero que la otra persona
se vaya no la ilusiones eso apesta
yo simplemente retomo lo que estaba
diciendo de cómo me criaron no considero
el engaño como algo bueno debes ponerte
en los zapatos de la otra persona si le
engaña piensa en cuánto daño puedes
causarle porque cuando me engañaron no
volví a tener una relación en unos seis
meses o un año
ahora deben unirse y decidir quién va a
eliminar
quién es el infiel creo que ya está
decidido
de acuerdo
abi
bien es posible que se equivocarán de
persona lo siento lo siento a vi les
conté cómo se desarrollaron las cosas
realmente fue algo bastante
cinematográfico creo que por eso la
gente pensó que yo era el infiel pero
cualquiera puede revisar mis mensajes
levanta la mano si crees que el infiel
sigue en la caja y te gustaría continuar
el juego
no pude centrarme en las personas que
estaban jugando
pero siento que el infiel no está entre
los que salieron de acuerdo significa
que el juego termina aquí si las luces
se ponen verdes significa que botaron al
infiel y todos ganan sin embargo si las
luces se ponen rojas significa que el
infiel sigue en la caja y pierden
[Aplausos]
y sabía lo sabía nadie
aunque se revele el infiel
en 3 en 2 en 1
me siento un tonto yo no soy así pero he
estado en ambos lados
yo he engañado y he sido engañada
cuando decidí por primera vez hacer esto
solo tenía una intención en mente que
era darle sentido
a mi dolor me engañaron en la
universidad fue la primera persona que
me hizo sentir que era suficiente pero
cuando me engañó sentí que me lo quito
todo
he estado luchando con eso desde
entonces para mí el dolor más grande no
fue ser engañada sino sentir que yo
había hecho lo mismo sí lo sabía porque
no lo hice mejor
entonces solo eso me lastimó sentí como
si ella fuera nuestro ex diciéndonos lo
que necesitábamos escuchar no pudimos
haber tenido una mejor infiel que mary
ann porque ella nos otorgó la
posibilidad de sanar y fue de gran ayuda
ya que los que habíamos resultado
heridos pudimos cerrar este ciclo
supongo
tienes la palabra mary ann
aunque gane
no quiero aceptarlo quiero darle este
premio en efectivo a las personas que
fueron engañadas
entonces invito a los que estaban
conmigo a subir al escenario
vamos a recibir el dinero y festejar se
los daré a ustedes
[Música]
este dinero es para ustedes no me
quedaré con nada por muchas gracias
pueden comprarme un trago si quieren
esto
vamos a recogerlo al final porque no
vamos a partirlo por todas partes